the deaths of a nine-year-old girl and
her twin six-year-old brothers at a
school bus stop in Indiana are raising
new current new concerns rather about
children's safety
a pickup truck hit the little kids and
another boy who was seriously hurt while
they were crossing the street to their
stop bus on Tuesday morning the truck's
driver a 24 year old woman is now
charged with three counts of reckless
homicide Dane Reynolds is meant is in
min tone Indiana Dean good morning this
is just such a terrible terrible story
good morning Gail unbelievable really
all three children who were killed just
about 24 hours ago attended this
elementary school here behind me and now
as you say there are questions about
whether school bus safety may have
played a role in this heartbreaking
tragedy troopers and first responders
don't do a lot of Kronik that seems like
this but today there was some tears shed
Indiana State Police Sergeant Tony
Slocum says just before sunrise Tuesday
morning nine year-old Olivia Stahl and
her twin six-year-old brother Xavier and
Mason Engel were struck by a truck and
killed while crossing a rural road to
their school bus all evidence so far
indicates the bus had its lights
activated and haven't stopped arm
extended it is illegal in all 50 states
to pass a school bus when it is stopped
with its lights flashing and stop arm
extended but by one estimate more than
15 million Americans illegally passed by
stopped school buses during the last
school year that's nearly eighty five
thousand times each school day cameras
have caught just how dangerous that can
be in Austin Texas a car slammed into
this child who just got off the bus he
was able to walk away and in Charleston
West Virginia a car just missed hitting
this child one of the solutions explored
is adding extended stop sign arms to the
side of the buses it does not appear the
bus in Indiana had
it's horrible that this happened elgyn
Engel is the uncle of Olivia Xavier and
Mason they were holding hands everyday
on the way to the bus stop including
today it looks like Olivia stepped in
front of the car for the boys
it looks like Olivia seen what was
happening and she stepped up like a hero
I wish she could have saved her brothers
but she's still a hero now the driver of
the pickup has also been charged with a
misdemeanor for passing a stopped school
bus she is now released on a fifteen
thousand dollar bond
meanwhile the mother of the 11 year-old
child who was seriously hurt yesterday
says he has successfully undergone three
surgeries but has a long road to
recovery ahead of him Nora I cannot
imagine what these parents are going
through Dean thank you